the internet is a buzz about Sony's new
Spider-Man and Jason film Madam web but
maybe not in the way the studio might
hope is it time for a new morbin time
Sony's Spider-Man universe that still
doesn't have a Spider-Man is developing
a less than Stellar reputation for
itself while superhero movie trailers
usually command attention and
anticipation that isn't happening with
its latest offering a trailer from Madam
web starring Dakota Johnson Adam Scott
and Sydney Sweeney the film isn't even
out yet and it's already earning the
collective ire of the internet and may
have already been mean more than morbius
people can have different opinions but
the collective consensus online seems to
be that Madam web looks not great from
poor dialogue to needlessly convoluted
Exposition Madame web has plenty of
people loving to hate it on the
worldwide web many on X formerly known
as Twitter were quick to point out how
the costumes in acting are reminiscent
of what one might see on a CW superhero
show others are already predicting very
low box office numbers how low seven
bucks one of the best things that come
out of morbius or maybe the only good
thing depending on who you ask was the
internet coining the phrase It's morbin
Time despite not being in the movie it
caught on quickly and became a meme
because it sounds like the kind of
cringey dialogue a movie like morbius
would have Madam Webb falls into that
camp and people have no qualms over
coming up with their own fake dialog for
the film one can spot a trend in the
YouTube comment section of the Madam web
trailer people mention loving a part of
the trailer that isn't there for example
one commenter wrote I love that part of
the trailer where she said it's webbing
time I cried tears of joy got a bit more
obscure with their jokes with one user
writing I love the part when she says
you know I'm something of a spider girl
myself and proceeded to web truly a
movie of all time this trend is repeated
ad nauseum under the video but the
common sentiment is clear no one really
respects this movie even boss logic who
makes custom posters and artwork for
superhero movies and is usually pretty
complimentary rote on X so looking
forward to it but Madame Webb should
have just released a teaser for now till
they had a trailer that will blow us
away but all the fake dialogue in the
world couldn't hold a candle to an
actual line in the trailer that's taken
on a life of its own one major complaint
against the Madam web trailer is that at
only 3 minutes long it gives away much
of the plot including the antagonist
backstory at one point Cassandra Webb
says he was in the Amazon with my mom
when she was researching spiders right
before she died that line the internet
would never be the same the clunky line
delivered with all the passion of a
fourth grader delivering a book report
for a book they didn't read has inspired
countless memes and jokes one user
posted a still from the room featuring
Tommy weo and imagine that his line
reading would be very similar to this
famous scene I did not hit her it's not
true it's B I did not hit her I did not
oh hi Mark they wrote it's not true it's
I did not go to the Amazon with your mom
when she was researching spiders just
before she died I did not oh hi madam
Webb what is it about this line that's
captured the internet's attention is it
how it cramps so much lore in a single
sentence honestly taking out the
superflous detail of she was researching
spiders would probably help it flow more
smoothly but what's done is done who
knows maybe more people will check out
Madame Webb when it comes out in
theaters on February 14th 2024 to see
what other mem worthy gems could be
hiding in it and again people may just
make up stuff and those who haven't seen
the movie will simply think it's
[Music]
true